On n'oublie jamais celle qui nous vole un baiser
ni celui
qui nous fait un doigt
Aaah enfoiré
Mon instinct me dit qu'il se passe un truc grave là-bas
et mes couilles me disent d'aller voir
Très mauvaise idée Mitch, on maître nageur nous
Moi mes couilles elles disent "si on la jouait relax"
Moi mes couilles elles disent "ferme ta gueule et allons voir ce qu'ils magouillent"
Tes couilles me font chier
Si Baywatch fonctionne c'est que nous respectons les consignes
Faites péter les shots
C'est une cata ce mec
Je suis Matt Brody
Et j'ai l'air d'en avoir quelque chose à foutre ?!
C'est l'un des nageurs les plus doués du monde
C'est comme si un humain avait baisé avec un jet ski
Ce qui est impossible bien sûr mais ce serait trop cool
Ça c'est ton lit ... Interdit de se branler dans mes draps
Et n'oublie pas j'ai des yeux partout
Oh putain
Léon apprenez-lui les bonnes manières amusez-vous messieurs
C'est l'heure du dodo enfoiré
Encore une cuillerée pour Baba
Vu les circonstances les choses auraient pu être bien pires
Ah ! Un pied ! *cris*
Ramasse-le ça porte bonheur
Il faut fouiller la morgue pour trouver des preuves
Vois s'il y a des traces de piqûres sur le périnée
Tu me demandes de faire quoi là ?
Soulève ses bourses et vérifie
Ok c'est un périnée ...
Regarde mieux
Ça pue le yahourt
Ça y est je vois un trou ... ah non c'est son trou de balle c'est tout
Cheese
Je vais le poster ça
Je t'interdis de poster ça
C'est jamais que des mains pleines de boules
Vous avez déconné le port de plaisance c'est pas les X Game
On faisait du sauvetage en mode interpellation
Oh ok au temps pour moi
À part que c'est du foutage de gueules le sauvetage en mode interpellation